now this is the this is the story of a
young man a law school graduate who paid
off his student loan huge student loan
with cash how do you do something like
this we're joined now by alex kenji
toronto-based president of O'Leary
ventures a start-up investment company
owned by kevin O'Leary hi Alex how are
you hi shine how are you how are you hey
good nice to hear from you re tell me
about this you paid off what a hundred
and fifteen thousand dollars student
loan that's right yeah I did and I
posted the receipt on Facebook just very
spontaneously and the next morning it
had kind of gone viral quite
unexpectedly and all I know it's
unbelievable why did was interesting is
not only you paid it off but you paid it
off with cash how did that happen Alex
well you know I went to my first my bank
where I had deposited the the cash that
we got when i sold my my first startup
from before I worked for Kevin and when
they asked me how would you like the
money I thought well you know this is a
big moment in my life why not make it
hilarious and I said you know but I'll
take it in cash because I had to walk it
of course across the other bank that had
my my student oh yeah so um so you know
and what people have found really
interesting is is how much of a hard
time the two banks both gave me so the
the first bank you know really didn't
want to do it and the second bank didn't
want to it didn't want to take the money
initially really that's funny isn't it
it's legal tender was cash money I I
thought so you know but but they all
they all had a good laugh with me at the
end so you know it worked out nicely so
you sold off a company good for you
going to college getting a degrees and
also running a company that was
obviously profitable you get a hundred
and fifteen thousand dollars cash did
you have armed guards and a bulletproof
vest as you as you walk to the other
Bank I i did not i had my wife but yeah
you know she protects me it must have it
must have felt pretty good Alex because
you know a lot of people take years and
years to pay off their student loans it
did you know and you know I guess I'm
luck
because for me I know for sure now that
it was all worth it and follow people
have to sometimes wait a lot longer
before that becomes clear what do you
attribute your success to what why have
things worked out so well for you I I
don't think I'm so different from a lot
of other people who take on a lot of
student debt I mean for me I i went into
an entrepreneurial stream I guess so I I
was okay with taking you know pretty big
risks and you know I would had to live
with it either way I they worked out or
not so I think you have to have some
humility and and and for the role of
luck and everyone's life you know some
people you posted that receipt as you
said it kind of went viral some people
say like aw he's just bragging this
guy's just bragging and making us all
feel bad and you know how do you respond
to that I you know that I really didn't
mean to do that and really sorry if it
seemed that way for some people I
definitely did not mean to rub it in
people's face that's best for sure you
know I realized that you know for a lot
of people it takes a lot longer and like
I said it could have been me just as
easily had the company not worked out as
well as it did or not been sold so
quickly so yeah but but surely you have
the right to celebrate some success
right you're celebrating it just put it
out there woohoo i paid off i stood
alone that's bad that's true and that's
how I was really trying to do it so I'm
glad you better you see it that way well
Alex what's what's next for you you got
this paid down that's fantastic well
what are you up to right now I I have
the coolest job ever i think i'm working
with kevin o'leary who's one of Canada's
most well-known and successful
entrepreneurs and what we're building
some really exciting new companies with
him he really wanted somebody who was
both young and hungry but also had
experienced building successful
companies that grow really quickly and
so he found me and and we're building
some really exciting businesses we're
building a mortgage business so
Canadians will be able to take out on
O'Leary mortgage I'm designed to be
easier to understand it easier to live
with than what people are used to seeing
today we're going into the biz so so by
the end of the summer you'll be able to
get a weary wine the idea Billy being
also you know taking his brand of just
making making things simple and easy to
understand and honest and direct and
putting that into a really something
that's usually very complicated like
wine so you know one red one weight that
you
always going to be good for a good value
I'm kind of kind of a shameless plug
there but I'm excited you can plug away
Alex but we have to leave it there we're
up against the clock great to talk to
you and a great story thanks so much for
sharing it with us appreciate it how
much grabbing me son I really appreciate
it